the bigger the monster the greater the
hero the things that we go through work
on us more than we work on them and in
this video what i want to break down is
the things and how we call the traumatic
events that happen and how we view them
can change how they affect us and how
they create us and shape us as people
and i was recently interviewed in a
two-hour podcast with graham stefan if
you don't know who i am i'm alex ramosey
i own acquisition.com we own a portfolio
company that is about 85 million a year
and i have nothing to sell you all right
and so on this podcast probably the most
shared and retweeted and cut section is
a section i'm about to show you um it
was where i got into it with one of the
other the the interviewee or interviewer
of the podcast uh talking about trauma
specifically we get to some really deep
stuff and i think that you get a lot of
value from it if you've never watched
any of our videos welcome to mozi nation
lots of love and i'll see you guys in
the next couple seconds would you
consider yourself emotional yeah i mean
probably i think i have emotions got it
because a lot of the times at least in
my experience like and and what i've
seen people that are nihilus it's easy
to that's like an easy out if something
bad happens if something good happens
it's just like oh yeah that's fine sweep
it under the rug it's not it's not it
matters anyways so bad happens it's not
like you actually deal with the process
whatever you know event or action
occurred that make you felt that emotion
if we believe that we have to like why
should we why should you feel that
emotion like why should we process a
traumatic event like what does that mean
well i do believe that there are you
know things in your brain biologically
that if they are deprived of something
or there's like some bad traumatic event
or something like that will affect your
biological dramatic versus non-traumatic
i mean i feel like the definition of the
word trauma would probably but what
would be the line between like okay and
like let's let's give an example of
something terrible actually not because
it's a podcast and people might hate on
crap so let's just say something bad
happens that we describe as bad in this
culture in another culture that might
not be bad it's trauma in this culture
it's not trauma in this culture so if
the circumstance is the same why was it
traumatic circumstances weren't the same
why not because the culture the facts
were the same will we describe the facts
as changed which means that we can
choose to cause something trauma but
wouldn't isn't it doesn't it make sense
that people would be built up due to a
culture and environment 40 year old guy
sleeps with a 15 year old girl terrible
rewind 200 years four-year-old guy
sleeps with a 15-year-old girl 100
normal how is it trauma now and not
trauma that and mind you like this is
not my state i'm just i'm you have to
pull an extreme example if we're going
to talk about trauma to illustrate the
concept so if it's traumatic in one
instance and not traumatic in another
then it means that we can basically
change the cultural narrative that we're
ascribing to our context and make it not
traumatic that makes sense which means
it didn't matter which means the only
thing that matters that you chose to
make it meaningful but let's say like
like the the the passing of a parent or
like a 1100 or something like that if we
think we feel like we have a narrative
that says if i don't mourn it means i
didn't care about them right that's a
statement of belief i could say that if
i don't mourn about them it means i
totally cared about them like why does
my morning have any indication of how
much i cared they're non-correlates
right but it's just because we have like
we have so many of these belief
statements that quote society are things
that we inherit but we just choose to
say that this is how life is and so i
think it's just like monitoring what
those statements are and so like one of
my favorite one of my favorite sayings
probably like if i had one thing on my
tombstone it would be it would be a
permutation of
a quote by orson scott card which is we
question all of our beliefs except for
those that we truly believe and those
who never think to question that's a
good club right yeah so it's like we
like oh of course i'm opening to
question my beliefs it's like what's
trauma like when someone's like i was
traumatized it's like were you or do you
just choose to label this trauma and
then now you [ __ ] up the rest of your
life because you call it trauma when 200
years ago it was life and a thousand
years ago having your parent killed in
front of you was just nature if you want
to go biology and so we're just like we
just choose to create meaning around
things and so like at the end of the day
like end to end end bottom bottom bottom
root yeah all our brains do is just
create and destroy meaning and so we say
this is a threat this is not a threat we
make like we need to reinforce this
behavior we don't need to reinforce this
favor all through meaning and so if you
can control what you deem meaningful you
can massively shift the odds in your
favor because you don't need to ascribe
meaning to well couldn't that be let's
say like like 500 years ago you see like
a parent killed in front of you isn't
that because all you have in your mind
is like food shelter water sure and now
that we have those things taken care of
our minds go to other places sure i just
don't think it changes the actual facts
so it's like we have we there's there's
stimulus response right and so like we
get to control the response we control
the stimulus was it um it's either
seneca or epictetus who's like no one
yells at a rock right so it's like if
you are the rock then like just it
doesn't matter right like you just like
eventually like people just [ __ ] off and
just leave you alone and so like and if
you if you see stimulus of life that way
in terms of like how you deem things or
label things traumatic or not dramatic
or good or bad you know it's the same
thing i'm sure like the hate comments
and whatnot is like if you deem the
comments of of the fans as meaningful
then you will both care about them being
positive and you will care about them
being negative but if they're not
meaningful at all to begin with then
like i don't think you can do either i
think you just either have to
participate in both sides or you remove
that is also a belief statement right so
like maybe you can so you know
interesting thoughts so how did you
transition from pro assume
i'm assuming you used to care a little
bit more about beliefs and stuff like
that how did you transition from that to
now not caring and did you have to
completely change your mindset to where
your automatic response to things was
just like what are these chains of
emotions and like the cultural
constraints and stuff like that that are
making me feel this way yeah that did
you just switch that light switch or do
you still on occasion catch yourself
slipping
right now i was like i just said that as
a belief right that's what i figured 100
yeah i mean i think you systematically
you hear like that's why the talking is
so important like what words are we
using what do those words mean like you
say drama like define that what do you
mean by that which is why like when you
hear really good writing that's academic
like the first few pages will be like
we're going to talk about this and this
is how we define this and this is how we
define this it's like we're putting
constraints around the words that we're
using because they mean they equate to
thoughts they're just buckets right that
we like say a word like trauma and like
it means something different to all
three of us so it's like we have to
agree on the definition before we can
talk about it that make sense
um and so no i had um so i i definitely
made a conscious effort when i was like
19 or 20 i became a born-again christian
um
the dunk the whole thing was like oh my
god life's amazing jesus is great and
then i ended up falling away from that
because i was like i don't know if this
is true and then i spent the next five
years dedicated to apologetics which is
defense of faith of the christian faith
so just learning the arguments around
like why christianity
like
is true right i ended up not believing
in it and i can give a variety of
reasons but i'll give you the simplest
one hopefully i'm not insulting anyone
this is just my belief that i'm sharing
which is a lot of one of the biggest one
of the strongest arguments for
christianity against other world
religions is that other world religions
say like if you go to the good place so
if you do a good job you go to the good
place right and fundamentally that's
it's a hard paradigm because it means
like at what point are you 51 good
versus 49 should have just held one more
door open and i would have gone to the
good place forever not even talking
about like finite circumstances and
creating infinite outcomes but like
whatever and so if you can draw that
line then it makes it it kind of makes
it ridiculous right it like kind of
breaks down on the like be a good person
system and so that's all world views
with the exception of buddhism and
christianity with christianity they're
like you don't have to be good you just
have to have faith if you have faith in
jesus then you go to the good place
right and so the the reason that for me
fundamentally i didn't believe in that
was because you actually create another
false binary which is belief or not
belief when in reality is to what extent
you believe it's how hard you believe
and again you create another 50 line
which is shy i believe one percent more
and then i would go into the good place
forever so anyways the point is is that
i i studied apologetics for a long
period of time and then i was really sad
and i was just like [ __ ] sad i was
like [ __ ] happiness i was like i'm just
going to do stuff that i think is cool
and that was like that was like the
first break in the chain for me um my
slogan myself was actually just about
happiness and that was wildly fraying
because i stopped judging myself for not
being happy and then i was just like oh
i'm like i am unhappy i'm like cool
whatever i just kept going and all of a
sudden just like stop mattering to me
like i don't think about it i genuinely
i don't think like does this make me
happy does not like i don't think about
it you just do what you want to do in
the moment do whatever you're doing and
it's not like it's like all short-term
like all pleasure-seeking whatever like
i still have a long-term perspective of
like this is what i want to build yeah
like i want to write these books i want
to build these courses i want to do this
stuff but it's like those are things
that i enjoy so that's what i that's
what i do i love it
it's great
all right
i mean i had questions but now i know
the answers to them just based off here
i'm just listening i'd rather just
listen and not say i know it's like i
don't want to mess it up
but then i created a belief that now i'm
going to mess it up oh god
why does it matter man yeah even matter
that i meant to begin with doesn't it
and you can't mess it up and then the
comments are going to be great no
they're not putting them in the comments
why does that matter i know it's i mean
i know it's crazy stuff but like i think
that like if you want to you can't do
what 99 of people are doing if you want
to be in the one percent yeah
fundamentally and so like you have to
have like what i would consider like
maybe uncomfortable conversations just
be like that's okay like cool like i
just i'm gonna do my thing and then
they're like
and the thing is a lot of times if you
just even just make your statements of
like this is how i believe like people
feel like you're attacking them
especially if you articulate it well
because they're like why i don't i'm
like cool like i don't get like do
whatever you want like it's all good to
me and so which is why i don't talk
about it as much publicly how about this
yeah what bothers you there's got to be
something out there that like i also
haven't wasted a lot of time
it's the only thing i don't have a lot
of this may seem like a silly question
but if you go to a restaurant and you
order something let's say you order a
steak and you order it medium well and
it comes back medium rare do you say
something not worth his time no i i
don't actually you don't no why would i
i don't care but at the same time i was
like well a lot of people would be
anxious to say something and i figured
you probably wouldn't care about those
emotions right i wouldn't even have an
emotion first i mean that's such a no
yeah yeah i mean maybe like like like we
have a big ad campaign that's supposed
to go out and like i get all the
creatives today before and it's supposed
to launch would that annoy me i'd be
like yes but let's fix it you know like
this is bad we can't run this let's try
again you know and in the end it won't
matter because we're all going to die
and this money is going to go back to
the game i'll give you this one analogy
this might be a good wrap up so this is
like my mental analogy that i make sense
to me which is like if if if life were a
game and all of us are given a token to
like enter like a casino because we're
in vegas right so we're all getting you
know a token we enter the casino we sit
down at the table to play poker right
everybody's playing everybody's got
cards and all you know we're dealt cards
everybody's dealt different cards and we
got to play the hand we're done and
depending on our level of skill we amass
more and more chips throughout the game
and um at the end of the game the
difference between the real world and
the casino in the
game of life in the real world you just
you go and you can cash out your chips
and you walk out with money and there
you go there's your day but i feel like
in the casino of life you get tapped on
the shoulder by the grim reaper he says
your time's up and then all your chips
get pushed right back to the middle of
the table and then you leave the casino
empty-handed because it was a fake game
with fake rules that didn't matter and
so like we accumulate these chips that
i'm just gonna push back in the middle
again that other people are gonna play
on and like the reason that that analogy
became real for me is like i bought this
piece of land in austin and i was like
that's neat and then i was like how many
people have owned this piece of land
it's like the guy you know the guy
before me owned it and the guy before
him owned it the guy before him doing it
and i was like and they were like this
is mine and they die or they sell it and
someone was like this is mine it's like
they're just chips that just get played
with and they just get amassed and then
they get redistributed it just doesn't
matter like death taxes everybody 100 so
like everyone's like estate planning
it's like dude 500 generations from now
a your your offspring are you know 500
to the you know 0.5 or you know one half
to the 500th power of like deluded
they're basically just humans at that
point so if if your wealth somehow is a
big enough that it can be diluted that
that much and lasts that long the people
who own it are just humans so like
they're so they're just as close to me
as you are you know it doesn't matter um
and then the alternative is the people
that i'm giving this to are just the
ones that i care about are the immediate
family but then when people get
resources that they didn't learn how to
use or manage then it destroys them
because it's too much potential energy
they can't handle it and so it's like
it's really for nothing and so like if
you want you can build something that
you think is cool but like at the end of
the day like we're just going to cash
the chips in so anyways alex's world
views but
it's a great analogy
just start to think about this one yeah
i don't have to rewatch this but you
know you know what's funny i was
actually thinking i would yeah i
remember listening to podcasts
this segment i would actually listen to
this yeah money income no earth
[Laughter]
investing indexes
savings accounts what credit cards
that's good geez thank you so much thank
you alex for coming on this has been an
incredible podcast yeah i think so i
appreciate i appreciate you having me
and to the audience like i know that a
lot of the stuff that i say can be uh
triggering and i know that at different
points in my life if i had heard someone
say what i'm saying in the position that
i am i would be offended um and i want
to make it clear that it's not my
intention to do that um at all
it's just me sharing beliefs that
as i understand the world and that
there's no way projection on you or how
you see the world etc it's just this is
how i see the world and these are
beliefs that served me well
that helped me overcome a lot of things
that i thought mattered you thought
there we go that was it that should be
our intro yeah that could be our intro
on
that's a good segment to put right there
in the beginning because it's going to
catch people's day where they were like
what what's offensive
what am i going to disagree with perfect
let's do that thank you so much thanks
for coming on man it was nice meeting
you too thank you good luck on your
tinder date thank you thank you should
grow the stash out by that you think so
i mean if you want to see that's why i
shaved it last night by the
way oh yeah